we continue our series in your
neighborhood and today
nate is live in the far northwest valley
but this time alex he's not going to go
centennial bowling he is centennial
sitting today nate tannenbaum exploring
the neighborhood of centennial hills in
the far northwest valley right around
where the 95 meets the 2 15.
and he has zeroed in on a real hidden
gem up in the northwest valley good
morning to you nate
how's it going well good morning hi alex
hi john well i'm not sitting now i'm
standing up i was sitting a half hour
ago across the street a little
restaurant that's not open and also
you can talk all you want about the
pizza but it's not open okay
we are in the village of centennial
springs and this is
tucked away in a cozy spot east of the
95
south of durango and farm road
even though norman rockwell lane where
we are is only a couple of blocks long
there's as much going on here as any of
rockwell's famous paintings of americana
from restaurants and residential to new
mixed-use construction
there's also a park at the end of the
street named after one of the most
prominent citizens of the early days of
las vegas
cp pop squires many of the buildings
here have businesses at the street level
and apartments in the upper floors
very cool setup up here in centennial
springs but
also as all of southern nevada works
through the pandemic
there's one place that's been working to
bring the community
together the city of las vegas community
center and ymca
inside this building there are swimming
lessons for preschoolers tai chi lessons
for seniors and just about everything in
between
elena sloans says tai chi is just right
for her
as i've gotten older it seems like the
the kindest exercise as the body ages
it has a lot to do with inner strength
and i think that is important right now
she showed off her practice sword said
the master even suggests a
fan that could be used for
self-protection in addition to cooling
off
then celia mori comes to the y for two
reasons
they offer child care for my little one
while we
parents work out and we are doing swim
lessons twice a week as well
he's not crying with the child care i'm
surprised and
i looked in the windows and he was
dancing with everybody and celia thinks
everyone's starting to see light
at the end of the pandemic tunnel we go
to a lot of the city parks
the centennial hills park has a splash
pad which we've been going to
and parents do socialize and talk her
almost two-year-old son tom
was also feeling social can you wave
high
yeah oh
such a cutie and lots of people coming
and going inside that community center
so i think we really are making progress
all in this neighborhood now coming up
in the next half hour we're going to
visit the bicycle shop across the street
here on
norman rockwell lane you're going to
meet the owner whose passion
started as a teenaged bmxer and how he's
working to bring bicyclists of all ages
together so we're having fun
in your neighborhood up here in
centennial hills uh the sun's starting
to come up it's a little breezy but it
is beautiful and
it's uh been fun exploring up here john
and alex
oh my gosh nate tom's little foot on the
stroller
he's so cute i'm saying she's serious
she watches
like a contortionist there
how cute love that thanks nate